[MUSIC PLAYING]
VALLIAPPA LAKSHMANAN:
Good afternoon.
Welcome to Next.
I'm going to be talking about
how to leverage AI on the cloud
so that you can
transform your business.
I'm Valliappa Lakshmanan.
Everyone calls me Lak.
And this talk comes
about after having
talked to dozens of
customers over the years
in terms of basically answering
a very simple question.
All right, I'm hearing
all of this hype about AI,
but where do I actually use it?
What kinds of use
cases come to mind?
And typically the
answer to this is,
you show them a
laundry list of, here's
a whole bunch of people
who have used it.
And what I have
tried to do here is
to step back from
that a little bit
and come up with principles, the
kinds of things that you see,
the very broad areas.
And we can basically look at it
from a couple of perspectives.
One way is I'll
talk about how you
see these in Google products.
And I'll also talk about
how we see these in terms
of our customer's use cases.
So when I talk about AI,
and when you hear our AI,
you probably think of
things like Google Photos.
You think of things
like Smart Reply.
These are incredibly buzzworthy.
You hear about image
models and sequence models.
If you're a
technical person, you
think about convolutional neural
networks, and recurring neural
networks, and LSTMs, et cetera.
But when you talk
about how do I use AI,
I would encourage you to
forget about all of that buzz.
Because ultimately, what
drives value in most companies
is machine learning on
structured data, data that
lives in a database, data that
lives in a data warehouse,
even at Google.
And this is something
that we did because--
it's possible to
do because you can
go through the entire
Google codebase
and look at all of the models
and see what kind of margins
are people using.
An MLP is a
multilayer perceptron.
It's essentially your
standard neural network
with nothing fancy in it,
just having a few layers.
That is 60% of all
the models at Google.
And this is the kind of model
that you use if you have a--
if you have data that is
just numeric and categorical,
just structured data.
LSTMs are the kind
of model that you
use if you have time series
data or the kinds of models
that you use if you
have text data--
translation, text summarization.
Smart Reply is an
example of an LSTM model.
That is another 30% of
all the models at Google.
So all of the
buzzworthy image models
that we hear about, that
every tutorial talks about,
that everybody puts
on their slide to say,
this is what you can do
with AI, that's less than 5%
of the models.
So what do you focus
on when you say I
want to use AI in my business?
Structured data.
So that's the first
thing to remember,
It's that the value
actually comes from the data
that you have in
your data warehouse.
So how do we use structured
data for AI and then when we
talk about buzz again, what--
we talk about AI, and then we
talk about machine learning.
And machine learning is the
part of AI that works today.
So again, when we talk
about what do we do?
Machine learning, right?
So how do we use
machine learning?
It's essentially a way to
use standard algorithms
to get predictive
insights from data
to make repeated decisions.
So let's break that
down a little bit.
The first thing, of course,
is that machine learning only
works when you have data, and
preferably lots and lots of it.
So you have the data, but unlike
the traditional, typical ways
that you use your data,
the difference here
is that the algorithms
that you apply to your data
are standard.
So whether you're
a retail company,
or you're an oil
and gas company,
or your a media company, the
way that you take your data,
the algorithms that you apply
are relatively standard.
And that's basically what
has driven this big use,
this big growth in
the applications
of machine learning.
It's a fact that the
same kinds of models
work across industries,
work across verticals.
So you apply these standard
algorithms to the data.
But that's-- those standard
algorithms themselves
aren't new either.
When you talk about
decision trees or you
about random forests, they've
been around for a while.
And those are what I mean
by a standard algorithm.
A decision tree is
a standard algorithm
that you can apply regardless
of which industry you're in.
But the key thing is that you
apply these algorithms to data
to create predictive insights.
Normally when we look at
data, what are we doing?
We are creating
backward-looking insights.
We're looking at your data and
you're saying, what happened?
You're trying to
understand what happened.
Machine learning is about
doing a predictive thing,
predicting something
that happened.
But that's not it.
Until this point, I could
be explaining everything
that a business analyst does
pretty much at every company.
The big difference between
what a human analyst does
and what a machine
does is this last bit.
It's a repeated decision bit.
The idea is that you
don't apply machine
learning if you need to
make a decision once a year.
If you need to make a
decision once a month,
that is not an ML use case.
An ML use case is
a decision that you
make over and over again,
many, many, many times a day.
It's the kind of thing
that you do every time
a customer visits you.
If you want to determine,
is the shopping cart
going to be abandoned?
Now, that is a
decision that you have
to make for every customer
who visits your web page.
If you're trying to
make a decision of,
should I place my new
store in this location?
That is a decision that you
may make 50 times a year.
The 50-times-a-year decision
is not a good candidate
for machine learning.
The thousands and millions
of decisions a day,
that is a great candidate
for machine learning.
And somewhere in
between, you have
to make a judgment call of
whether this is a data analysis
task, or is it a
machine learning task.
So, to give you an example of
where this idea comes about,
let me start with Google.
So our flagship application
is, of course search.
We are a search company.
And the way search used
to work a few years ago
was that you would go
into the Search bar,
and you would type in
the keyword Giants,
and we had to show you either
the San Francisco Giants, which
is a baseball team, or
the New York Giants, which
is a football team.
Which one do we show you first?
Well, the way this
used to work was
that there was a rule base deep
in the bowels of the search
code that said if
the query is Giants,
and if the user is
located in the Bay Area,
show them results of the
San Francisco Giants.
If the user is in
New York, show them
results of a New York Giants.
And the user or
somewhere else, show
them results about tall people.
And that is basically the rule
base for that one word giants.
Imagine how complex
the code base
gets for every single thing that
could have multiple meanings.
So that's essentially
the problem
that your field is
facing because we
are writing hand-coded
rules like this for each
of these query phrases.
And machine learning comes
about because we say,
this is a decision that we have
to make over and over again,
and we need to make it
lots and lots of times.
So how do we scale
this so that we
don't have to have
someone basically create
this rule for every
single possible query
term that could exist?
And that's basically
what prompted RankBrain,
which is essentially a machine
learning algorithm that started
from this premise that, hey,
when someone comes to our web
page and they do a
query, we show them
a list of possible results,
we know which of them the
actually clicked on.
So now we can train a
machine learning model
to basically predict what the
best possible result ought
to be for a specific query term.
And we have enough
examples of this.
We don't have to go run
and create separate rules
for every one of
the query terms.
We basically have a machine
learning model do this for us.
So it's-- search is not
purely machine learning.
There are many, many,
many signals that we use.
But the machine learning
signal turned out
to basically create
the kind of improvement
that we see over two years
of work, that one signal did.
And that was amazing.
And that basically was what
prompted Google to sit up
and say, man, this machine
learning thing, it has legs.
So what does that
essentially say?
So here's another example.
This is of our customers.
So Rolls-Royce-- basically,
you say Rolls-Royce,
and you think cars, but
Rolls-Royce also does shipping.
And they needed to basically
interpret marine data sets.
And again, the way they would
do this was basically it
was a humongous data set.
They needed lots
and lots of rules.
And those rules had
to be crafted by hand.
And they were basically able to
create safety measures simply
by-- basically, instead of doing
this rule creation by hand,
by basically taking
those marine data sets
and inferring what
kind of actions
ought to be taken
through machine learning.
So the basic idea, the
first premise here, where--
how do you use AI?
How do you use machine learning
to leverage your business?
Number one, look back
into your business.
Think about all the problems
for which you are creating rules
today, any problem for which
you're creating rules today.
And you have been
doing the good thing,
which is every time you've
made a rule-based decision,
you basically have a
data set that says,
this is the information
I use to basically--
the information that went
into your decision tree
to do the rule and the outcome.
Was it actually correct or not?
If you identified fraud
using a bunch of rules,
was this transaction actually
fraudulent, or was it not?
So that's your label.
And if you've been doing
this rule-based, data-driven
decisions for a
period of time, that
becomes a machine
learning data set.
And you can basically get out
of this business of handcrafting
rules and basically turn it
over to a machine learning
model, which can
basically infer what
the rules ought to be, and to
do this in a more holistic way.
So number one, how
do you basically
leverage AI in your cloud?
Look at all your
rule-based systems.
rule based systems.
Look at all the
systems, especially
for which you have been
collecting outcomes.
If you've not been collecting
the outcomes for the decisions
that you're making,
please start,
start saving whether those
decisions actually worked out
or didn't.
And use those as basically the
input to your machine learning
models.
So that's number one.
So let's take a second use case.
And in this case, I'll be
using Google Maps to illustrate
the machine learning journey,
the journey of a company that's
basically going from--
going through the machine
learning transformation.
So I use Google
Maps all the time.
And I live somewhere in
the south of that diagram.
And I work in Google Kirkland in
the north part of the diagram.
And every day.
I look at Maps, and
Maps gives me a route
to get from home to work.
So great.
And I can look at that.
But is that machine learning?
And you could say, well, I
told Google where I live.
I told Google where I work.
And this is basically the route.
And going from A to B, this
is Dijkstra's algorithm.
This is the A-star algorithm.
We teach it in undergraduate
computer science classes.
It's a deterministic algorithm.
So it's not machine learning.
Going from A to B is
not machine learning.
So, it is essentially
a deterministic rule.
It's a rule that you can
write down on paper and do it.
How about this?
So I was in Japan.
And I was in a subway
station called Roppongi.
And Google Maps
essentially told me
that you're on floor number
two of Roppongi station.
And to basically
get to Google Japan,
this is a route that
you have to take.
How does Google Maps know
that I'm on floor number two
of the subway station?
GPS-- I mean, this
is underground.
I'm not going to get
altitude out of it.
So at that point, the only
way to know where I am
is to basically use a whole
bunch of other data sources.
But the point is to
get to that stage
where you're now
thinking about how
do I figure out
where the user is
from a variety of
different data sources,
you have to have solved
problem number one, which
is how to get from A to B. That
is the core of your business.
Basically provide navigation
information from A to B,
and then you're basically
then saying, OK,
now how do I use data, how
do I use ML models basically
improve that experience?
And that's what
that second bit is.
It's about improving the
core business experience
that you do with number one.
And then you get the
icing on the cake, which
is looking at a Google Now Card
that says, this is where I am,
what can I do in
between meetings?
And I was able to suggest
to me that I should go look
at the Santore Museum of Art,
which has the kind of paintings
that I like.
Now, if you're a sports
fan, it might have probably
suggested to you a sumo
wrestling match close by.
But the point being that this
is now completely personalized.
And it's still in that
same realm of location,
and location-based
services and giving you
that additional information.
So this is basically the journey
that enterprises go through
with machine learning.
You start with the
core of your business
that you typically solve
and you have already solved,
and then you look at
how to basically address
individual use cases
of that experience,
of that user experience
in a better way.
And then finally, you look
about how do I basically
reach that very long tail
of that very rare situations
that we need to do
very, very well in?
So let me take in
another example of this.
This is in the case of, again,
talking about this journey
to give you an idea
of how this works.
Let's say that we
want to basically--
we are a media
company, and we want
to find the best time
slot for a TV show.
So how do we do this?
Well, we might basically
have data that says,
OK, here's the
age and the number
of viewers of that
particular age
group who basically have viewed
shows like this show before.
And I have location
information of people who have
viewed this show in the past.
And then based on the
location information,
based on the demographic,
based on the desirability
of that demographic,
I would basically say,
OK, we're going to
take this new show,
and it looks like
7:30 PM on Wednesday
is the best time
slot for this show.
This is essentially your
traditional data analysis.
There is no machine
learning here yet.
But in order to do this,
what data have you collected?
You've basically
collected a bunch of data
around the demographics of
people watching the show.
You basically found the genre
of each of your different shows.
You know where the location
is of all of these people who
have been watching these shows.
So now given all of
this information,
can we do the next thing, the
second step of that journey?
What's the second
step of the journey?
Let's build a movie
recommendation system.
We might say, OK,
let's go ahead and say
let's build a movie
recommendation system.
And your first approach,
the simple approach
would be something like this.
You would say, I'm going
to recommend popular movies
in the genre that
this user likes.
So if I have a user who's
between 30 and 39 years old,
he's male, makes between
$50,000 and $100,000,
and lives in South
Korea, and over time I
know that this person has
watched a romantic com--
like a romance, two comedies
followed by romance,
followed by a comedy, then
my prediction algorithm
might be, let me go
ahead and find the genre
that the user has
watched most often--
in this case, it's comedy--
and then let me go
find where they live--
which is South Korea--
and find the five most popular
comedy movies in South Korea.
And that is my movie
recommendation for that user.
It's a pretty straightforward,
rule-based algorithm
that basically takes
advantage of the data.
But the thing is it relies on
the data that you already have,
this structured data that you
have off the history of things
that a person has watched
and something that you know
about this particular user.
How does this become
machine learning?
You flip this around.
Notice that we have
a model, I have data,
and I have prediction.
Instead, you start
from the data.
You don't start from
this idea that I
know what the model ought
to be, and therefore I'm
going to go to that data, I'm
going to make my prediction.
Instead you start from the data.
You say, what's my data?
I have all the movies, and
I have all of the ratings
that every user has done
of all of the movies.
And then your model
is, if I'm going
to go ahead and do
a prediction, I'm
going to find all the
similar movies across all
the similar users using
criteria like the user's
current preference, and their
age, and a variety of things.
But notice here now, all
those very hard boundaries
of age, income, genre, none
of those exist anymore.
This is much more amorphous.
It can basically take into
account that people are not--
you can't bend them.
Instead, it's a very
continuous range.
And you're finding
similarity measures.
And that's basically what a
machine learning helps you do.
It helps you basically take
into account multiple factors
and weight them appropriately.
So this is essentially
that journey
that you go through
from forest--
basically taking your core
problem, solving it with data,
thinking about how
to take that data
and solve it with analytics,
and then using that data
and rethinking it in such a
way that you don't have to--
you can basically account
for different factors.
So in other words
then, the second thing
that you can do with
machine learning,
the second way that you leverage
your business of machine
learning, is that this
is how you personalize
your applications, and
this is how you basically
reach the people who are unlike
every other 30 to 39-year-old
who lives in South Korea.
You're able to find
smaller groups of people
that they're like and give
them much more targeted
recommendations.
So machine learning
is about basically--
I think mostly
what we do when we
do businesses is that
we basically say,
we're going to take the middle
part of our distribution,
and we're going to
target everything
towards the 80% of our users.
And we're going to forget
about the other 20% who
do crazy things.
But instead, what
machine learning
lets you do is that it lets
you basically go walk down
into that tail, and
basically for every user find
similar users and be able to
do recommendations for them.
So to get to the
third thing I'll
start with one of my favorite
quotes is what Andrew Ng.
Andrew Ng is, of
course, a famous machine
learning researcher.
And you would
think that he would
be the one who would be all gung
ho about the latest advances
in machine learning theory.
But instead, Andrew says, "it's
not about the best algorithm.
It's about who has
the most data."
Because that's the
other thing that we
have learned over
and over again is
that the best machine
learning algorithms
are the ones that have access to
more data than any other ones.
So when you look-- when
you compare two algorithms,
forget about what
everybody tells you.
If you have two products that
essentially do the same thing,
ask them what data
was this trained on.
If you have two image
models, ask them
what data was it trained on.
And if one model was trained
on more data and better data
than the other one, that--
it doesn't matter what the
quality of the algorithm
is, that data is basically
going to control the quality
of the result that you get.
So inevitably it's about the
data, the quality of the data,
and the quantity of the data.
So, what does that
have to do with the way
we approach our data
stewardship because everything
starts with data management.
If you think back about
how you collect your data--
and this is something that
I'm now noticing now--
is lots of times what we
do is that we take our data
and we aggregate
it, and we store it,
and we try to build
algorithms, machine learning
algorithms and data analysis
tasks, on the aggregated data.
What do you mean by that?
Instead of doing
machine learning
on every individual
transaction, you're
try to forecast
sales by aggregating
all the transactions over
days and take the daily data
and use it to predict sales.
That doesn't work because
what have you just done?
You've taken this
very rich data source
that you have of every
individual transaction that
has ever happened, and
you've thrown it all away,
and you've combined everything.
And now you basically have
a data set of 365 points.
And you're trying to use
that to predict sales.
Stop.
Don't train your
model on 365 points.
Go back to that
original data where you
had 80 million transactions.
You need to train your models
not on the filtered data, not
on the aggregated data,
but on the raw data,
on the original data.
So that's-- machine learning is
about doing things on as much
data as you can.
Don't aggregate
things too early.
Don't filter things too early.
Don't throw away data too early.
That doesn't mean that you
shouldn't clean things up,
you should make sure
they're good quality.
We're saying that try
to get it to the point
where you don't need
to throw away data,
that you don't need to
aggregate this data to reduce
the noise in it, that each
individual transaction data has
the right information that
you need to build a better
machine learning model.
But it's not just about
the data that you have.
Also think about all
the ancillary things
that affect your business.
So it's not just about
the data that you
have in your data warehouse,
think about weather data,
think about traffic data,
think about political events.
All these things that
affect your business, so
think about how to basically
join your data sets but all
these other diverse factors.
And that is the
data set that you
should be using to build
your machine learning models,
to build your AI systems.
And then, having now
taken your data warehouse,
considered all the third
party and partner information
that you can join with, ask
yourself a third question.
What data could I be collecting
that I'm not collecting today?
Sensors are getting
really cheap.
There are something
like $8 billion devices
that came online last year.
It's just an astounding number.
And this is just
connected devices.
I'm not talking
about devices that
are not permanently connected.
These are just
connected devices.
And they're-- it's getting
to the point where data is
ubiquitous, and you can get it.
The question is, are you
collecting the data that
actually impacts your business?
So make sure that you
have a data strategy that
involves collecting this
data from as many sources
as you can, whether their
phones, or their IoT devices,
or whatever.
And then, think about
how to basically take
that big data that
you now have--
and what I mean here
by big data is not
the quantity of the data,
unaggregated, unfiltered,
the raw data joined with
everything else that
affects you with streaming
data that's coming in.
In the old days, like the
three V's in other words--
volume, variety, and velocity.
So that's basically
what I mean here.
And that's actually-- when
you think about it that way,
and you thoughtfully consider
all of these things that affect
it, it's changing businesses.
Just take the first one, games.
10 years ago, games
were board games.
Now games are essentially
completely customized
to the person playing it.
The characters
that you encounter
when you play a game
are very different
and have different
skills than the character
that somebody else encounters.
And the only reason
that that is possible
is because of the amount of
data that gaming companies are
able to collect, and how
they're able to customize
the game as you play the game.
And you see this over and
over again as you walk down
that list of companies that are
getting completely transforming
by rethinking the data
that they're collecting
and what they can
do with the data.
So as an example of
another one, Schlumberger,
who's one of JCP's
customers, talking
about how Cloud IoT Core allowed
them to focus their engineering
efforts to basically build
reliable economic things.
They're talking about 30
terabytes of petrochemical data
that they can now use
to build their models.
So that's basically the scale
that you should be thinking at.
So the third aspect I
want to leave you with
is this idea that when you're
designing your systems,
design them with the
expectation that next year you
will have more data.
Don't start with
this defeatist idea
that the data that you
have is all the data
that you have today.
You will be able to get
more data next year,
and you want to basically
work towards getting that more
data, more diverse data,
and build your models
to account for that.
So that's the third aspect of
this, is design for more data,
for unfiltered,
unaggregated data.
To get another idea
of just talking
about the kind of
devices, and being
able to connect
them, and basically
create new businesses that just
didn't exist a few years ago,
many of us use things
like Philips Hue,
basically allows us to change
the way lighting works.
And now Phillips
basically processes
25 million remote
lighting commands a day,
something that--
a thing that did not
exist three years ago.
And it's just possible
because of all
of these trends that are
connecting together--
data, connected devices, the
ability to basically train
your models and basically
deal with unstructured data
like lighting commands.
But this is all great, but
what happens when you collect
petabytes and exabytes of data?
If you're going to be
spending all of your time
doing provisioning,
worrying about reliability,
worrying about handling
the growing scale,
if you're going to be
worrying about utilization,
you're not going to be deriving
value from any of this data.
You're going to be spending
all of your head count, all
of your human resources.
All of the engineers are
going to be basically just
working on keeping this data up.
And that's not what
you want to be doing.
You want to basically
be deriving data,
deriving value from it.
You want to understand the data.
And this is basically
something that we at Google
have a lot of experience with.
And this is kind of
why we've talked--
we've been basically building
serverless data analysis,
serverless ETL tools, serverless
machine learning tools.
The reason that pretty much when
you look at our data platform,
everything is serverless.
Everything is a
fully-managed service
is simply because there is
no way to do both things.
There is no way to both have
an engineer both be worried
about is the data going to
be there when I need it,
and being able to
collect and basically be
able to create models to
derive value from that data.
So even though I
think we started out
talking about MapReduce and
like the equivalent of these
in 2004, we quickly realized
that that cluster-centric way
of thinking wasn't
going to scale.
And we basically
moved on to things
like Dataflow, which is open
source to the Apache Beam,
to basically deal with this idea
that you want to do serverless
ETL, serverless extract
transform load, build
pipelines.
So don't think of
serverless as purely being
around low-level functions.
Serverless should be about
your entire workflow.
Your entire workflow
needs to be serverless.
And that's something that-- that
is the way that you basically
manage petabytes and
exabytes of data.
If you've used
BigQuery, you know
exactly how we think about it.
You think of-- you
write your SQL code,
and you don't worry
about the thousands
of slots that come up
to basically execute
those queries for you.
That is how you
should be thinking.
You should be thinking in terms
of code not infrastructure.
So and this is something that--
BigQuery is one of those
things that people immediately
get when they see it.
And it drives a lot
of transformation
and a lot of our customers.
AirAsia, for example,
said, hey, we just
need a platform that
can scale to basically
have our appetite for just
this amazing growth in data
that they're seeing.
And BigQuery was
ideal for that task.
So when you have this
increasing volumes of data,
and you need to continue
deriving value from it,
think about fully-managed,
serverless solutions.
Don't settle for anything
that involves you
having to spin up a cluster.
So the idea is spend time
on what you need to do.
Don't spend time
on how to do it.
So you focus on insight,
not infrastructure.
So another example of this is
Blue Apron, who talks about
after we moved to
BigQuery, or query time
was reduced exponentially.
So they were able to do a lot
more queries, and importantly,
accelerate the decision making.
An extra day is very,
very, very valuable.
And then, of course, the
other question that we get
is, but I have lots of data.
Can I really stop managing
all of this myself?
And my favorite anecdote
here is Evernote
because this is done by
our professional services
team, migrated three and
1/2 petabytes of content
in just 70 days.
And all of these are
just very small documents
owned by millions of users.
And we're able to do that.
And so it's definitely possible.
You can move fast.
And you can basically
get out of this
managing your own
infrastructure business.
So 4a, use a platform
that lets you
forget about infrastructure.
If there's a 4a,
there's got to be a 4b.
And what is that?
So this is about the data part.
But there's another bit
that any cloud platform
has to give you if you want
to be successful in AI.
And it is that you
need flexibility.
You need to have the ability
to basically do your machine
learning runtimes for
different scenarios.
For example, on
Google Cloud, you
can prototype with Cloud
Datalab or Deep Learning Image.
You can do this prototype
locally on your little laptop
and then run it
on-prem with Kubeflow
and migrate it over
time to ML Engine.
So it's giving you this
for different scenarios.
For example, if you have
a device out in the field,
and you want to be able to
run a model on that device,
you want to make sure
that your models are
portable such that you
can train on the cloud,
but do the prediction on
the device out in the field.
So you want to make
sure that any system
that you basically get and
you run your machine learning
runtimes on, this support all
these different scenarios,
training on the cloud,
predicting on the device,
training on the
device, et cetera.
The other thing to realize
is that deep learning only
works because our
data sets are large.
So the graph on
the left basically
talks about the
training data size.
This is for a specific problem.
But different problems , you
see the exact same thing.
So for those of you in the
back who can't quite see it,
the x-axis has 2 part 20, 2
part 21, 2 part 22, et cetera.
So each grid is a
doubling of the data size.
And each time your data size
doubles, your error rate
drops linearly.
So remember that
to drop your error
rate by x, you're basically--
your data set basically
has to go to a power of x.
Your data set doubles to get
to linear improvement in error
rate.
So it only works--
this drop in error, it
happens with more data.
But when we talk
about more data,
we're not talking
10% more data, we're
not talking 20% more data.
We're talking 1,000 times more
data, a million times more
data.
We're talking powers here,
lots and lots more data.
So that's the one thing
that we want to remember
on the left-hand side.
The right-hand side is the
other scary part of the curve,
which is these are the
machine learning models,
the state-of-the-art
machine learning models.
And the x-axis
there is the year.
And the y-axis is the compute
capability that you need,
petaFLOPS per day of training.
So AlexNet, which is on the
way left-hand side, that
is the thing that essentially
started the deep learning
revolution, is way down
in the corner there.
And again, the y-axis
there is logarithmic.
So every time a model
goes up in that grid,
the compute power is going 10
times, 100 times, 1,000 times.
For now, look at
the compute power
change the last six
years, from 10,000
on the top y-axis,
0.0001 on the bottom.
In other words, your compute
power that's needed to do
state-of-the-art machine
learning went up 10 million
times in the last six years.
Just let that settle
in for a minute.
The amount of data that you
need doubles, four times,
quadruples.
It goes in power.
The data requirement
goes in powers.
The model requirement
So you basically have
two power laws going on.
And this is kind of why
your traditional chips,
architecture, Moore's law,
they don't really work anymore.
That is-- this is the thing
that our leadership saw
three or four years ago that
prompted us to start developing
the TPUs, basically this
need to completely change
the game in terms of what kind
of data you need to handle
and what kind of computer you
need to be able to do this.
So, if you want to
do machines earning,
you need efficient,
cost-effective places
to do machine learning.
So when we offer that, we offer
Compute Engine to which you
can basically attach
CPUs, GPUs, or TPUs,
Kubeflow, which gives you
this hybrid environment,
and Kubernetes Engine, which
gives you a great place
to run it on Google Cloud,
and Cloud ML Engine, which
gives you a
fully-managed serverless
way they use all
of this hardware,
and to basically do this
in a distributed way.
So the way you handle the
increasing amounts of data
is distribution.
And the way you handle the
increasing amounts of compute
is better and better
hardware chips.
So you need distributed
And that's basically what
something like ML Engine
gives you.
It gives you distribution,
and it gives you
the best of the breed chips.
You need both of
those in order to do
machine learning successfully.
And the other
thing to realize is
that machine learning is moving
towards increasing levels of ML
abstraction.
Sorry, you did not seenit.
I guess it's seenit,
so you already seenit.
So, let me just start with
three years ago what happened.
AUCNET is a Japanese
auction company.
And they wanted to
basically-- the way
they want to rethink the
way car auctions work.
The way it used to work was
that you wanted to sell a car,
and you would
basically go fill out
a form that said what car
you had, how old was it,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Filling out a form--
boring.
So what AUCNET did was they
said, oh, just go around
your car, take a bunch of
photographs of your car,
upload those photographs
to our cloud,
and we'll tell you how
much your car is worth.
Imagine the friction
between filling out a form,
take photos of your car.
Completely changed the business.
But in order to
do that, they had
to build a custom image model
so they could price the cars.
They had to do it.
They had to write the
tensorflow code themselves.
We helped them do it.
They wrote it.
It worked.
They changed their business.
Great.
But I'm talking about increasing
levels of abstraction.
So AUCNET wrote tensorflow code.
Next level up, Ocado.
Ocado is a UK grocer.
They wanted to basically
handle customer service emails.
The way it used to work was
a customer sends an email,
somebody at Ocado
reads the email, says,
oh, this customer is
basically saying something
about our produce.
And then they forward to
the produce department,
and the person in the
produce department
reads it and decides
what to do about it,
it's a pretty wasteful process.
So what did Ocado do?
They used the Natural Language
API, a Google API built
on Google data,
works out of the box,
but it's not going to basically
identify very specific things
that are Ocado-specific.
But it's going to
basically say the customer
is happy customer is
not happy, they're
talking about
produce, et cetera.
And then Ocado basically use
that NLP API and then built
a second model that
basically said,
if the NLP API gives you the
tags, which department should
you send it to?
So in other words, they did
not have to go to the raw text
and build a complete
model themselves.
They could basically
build off of the NLP API
and build a smaller,
easier model.
That is that abstraction
level that I'm talking about.
You don't-- as
technology is improved,
you increasingly don't have
to go down to this level
of dealing with raw
images, raw text.
You can basically build
on top of existing APIs.
Meanwhile, seenit wanted
to basically have--
it allows people to
basically upload content.
And sometimes people upload
inappropriate content
for whatever reason.
And so seenit
wants to reject it.
And they could rejected
using the Vision API--
straightforward,
just use it as is.
And then the next level up,
Uniqlo, a Japanese retailer,
basically need-- wanted to
basically create a chatbot.
And again, they don't need to
go down to programming each
of the individual
words, and what
they mean in conversations.
They could basically
write in tense,
this is what a
conversation is when
somebody wants to
find a matching blouse
for their shirt.
And the chatbot
is basically able
to take that and create
a realistic experience
for the user.
So you can think in terms of
not very low-level LSTM models,
but at very high level, what
is the customer's intent?
What is a typical
transaction that they're
going to walk through?
And this is how you do it.
So, if you are doing ML,
what does this mean to you?
It means that you
want to basically pick
a framework that lets you do at
every level of that abstraction
hierarchy.
You want to build a
low-level tensorflow model,
completely custom, no problem.
Use ML Engine.
If you want to basically use
out-of-the-box models that are
basically trained on massive
amounts of data, no problem.
Use a Vision API, the
Translate API, the Speech API.
You have something
somewhere in the middle,
you want to basically take
advantage of everything
that the Vision API gives
you, but customize it
to your own things?
Use AutoML.
You heard in that keynote today
that AutoML is no longer just
about vision.
We also text classification
in AutoML, the idea being we
can basically build
on top of Google here.
So, that is 4b.
When you think about how do I do
machine learning on the cloud,
realize that machine learning,
in spite of all the hype,
is ultimately is still software.
And you want to make a
buy versus build decision.
And you want to make
it based on quality,
based on the kinds of things
that you want to be able to do.
So with that, we'll
kind of summarize.
So number one,
machine learning can
be used to solve many problems
for which you're writing rules
today.
Number two, machine learning
is how you personalize
all your applications.
This is how you
reach the long tail.
Number three, design your
systems with this expectation
that you'll have a lot
more data next year.
And number four-- I've
combined the a and b here--
use a platform that lets you
forget about infrastructure
that gives you a lot of
great pre-built models.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]